se dirige-t-on vers une nouvelle hausse
du tarif unique du passe navigo la
question est clairement posée depuis une
semaine maintenant et cette table-ronde
organisée par le syndicat des transports
en ile de france le stif cette table
ronde organisée autour du financement
des transports publics où étaient
présentes notamment valérie pécresse
présidente de la région plusieurs
spécialistes également et ce constat est
nicolas le stif a besoin de trouver
rapidement de nouvelles pro 7 en effet
où ils fruits dont on va parler
franchement il va manquer de l'argent
dans les caisses du stif pour assumer
les ambitions de la région en terme
d'investissement c'était déjà le cas
l'an passé avec cette eau se
souvenez-vous de 3 euros du prix du pass
navigo c'était en août 2016 et bien la
situation va continuer de se tendre pour
les finances du stif entre 2017 et 2030
le style va investir environ 20
milliards d'euros dans les transports
franciliens avec par exemple 700
nouvelles rames promesse de campagne de
valérie pécresse la création de
nouvelles lignes comme le tram très
exposé dans les civils et puis il ya
aussi l'arrivée du grand paris express
en 2023 il faudra assurer l'entretien et
le fonctionnement de 200 km de métro
supplémentaires
et du coup nicolas c'est le pass navigo
le prix du pass navigo qui pourrait
augmenter alors rien n'est encore
officiel non se dirige très clairement
et très certainement vers une nouvelle
hausse du prix du navigo jusqu'à 3%
selon les premières informations ce qui
pourrait faire un pass navigo à 76 euros
par mois et coûté à ce propos stéphane
baudet vice président du syndicat des
transports d'île de france ça fait
quinze ans que chaque année en moyenne à
2 5% le pass navigo ou la carte orange
augmente donc c'est pas un sujet nouveau
et oui il continuera naturellement
d'augmenter la présidente s'est engagé à
ce qu'il n'augmente ce qui est pas ce
qui était un changement avec ce qui se
passait avant est-ce qu'il n'augmente
qu'avec de l'offre supplémentaire cette
année il a augmenté enfin l'année
dernière il a augmenté de 3 euros nous
avons eu de l'offre supplémentaire en
contrepartie ces salles engagement
politique qui est pris par la présidente
la hausse du passe navigo c'est la seule
piste envisagée non heureusement les
voyageurs n'ont pas être les seuls on va
dire à à payer l'addition la région
regarde ce qui se fait ailleurs en
europe un système par exemple d'heure
plein et d'heures creuses pourrait être
mise en place des tarifs spéciaux pour
les touristes également plus publicité
ou encore un péage urbain à l'instar
pour les voitures à l'instar du modèle
londonien sachez d'ailleurs outre fric à
londres l'équivalent du passe navigo
peut coûter jusqu'à 415 euros par mois
merci nicolas et puisque l'on parle de
transport et du stif sachez que le plan
d'amélioration des réseaux de bus
poursuit d'ici 2020 15 nouvelles lignes
seront renforcés et six nouvelles seront
mises en place depuis le 1er janvier et
quatre parcours ont fait l'objet de
nettes améliorations dont l'express sans
qui relie les mureaux à saint quentin en
yvelines